[Applaudissements]
vous avez vu que pop star revenait sur
sur des beats
je suis tellement contente d'en serait
d'ailleurs tout petit petit appel je
rêverais d'être dangereux une pop star
et ben voilà appel aux patrons de délits
ou là il est où d'ailleurs le patron de
deivid fait moi deschamps d'un patron je
vais lui dire voilà on va pas trop pour
sheryfa luna qui veut être dans le jury
de popstars s'aimait pas nous donner la
regarder sheryfa luna c'est du cuir de
vachette cdu du sénat camarguaise c'est
hugues aufray voilà c'est ça fait tout
ce qu'on aime
alors j'ai des gogos est ce que c'est
possible ce qu'il y avait peut-être une
possibilité d'un bilan et ma fille je
veux dans une télé sheryfa luna fasse
partie du jury de popstars
si oui quelles sont les modalités
d'usagé de données doit te donner un
chèque barré une fiche d'état civil
alors si c'est oui tout se passera bien
si c'est nous et ont donné que c'est une
amie on aura un plateau vide et voilà
ici la dame demoiselle là bas donc voilà
toile d'oracle bonjour série phare je
pense qu'on peut se proposer c'est
peut-être de se caler un petit rendez
vous la semaine prochaine avec alexia
laroche joubert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est que ça se passe comme ça s'est
produit par alexia faut aussi qu'alexia
alors son accord à l'excès alex est
d'accord sinon on la vire de touche pas
à mon poste bien convenir ses mots elle
est d'accord mais sheryfa on se verra la
semaine prochaine ou la semaine suivante
avec alexia je m'y engage on va faire un
rendez-vous pour discuter de ça ouais
cyril tu sais que voilà tu tues tu
cherches lyon sera le garant merci
[Applaudissements]